نتعرف معكم على ذهب عيار 14 هذه المره
مزاياها عيوبه والفرق بينه وبين ذهب عيار
الثمانيه عشر عيار 18 يحتوي على 75% من
الذهب الخالص اما عيار 14 فيتكون من نسبه
58% من الذهب الخالص
ينتشر عيار 14 من الذهب في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بريطانيا والغرب بشكل
كبير حيث يمثل عيار 14 حوالي 90% من
مشتريات الامريكيين لخواتم الخطوبه يتميز
لها بعيار 14 بصالباته وذوقه الرفيع من
ناحيه التصميم ووفقا للخبراء فهو ذو اللون
الاقرب الى اللون الذهبي المعروف عند
الجمهور مما يجعل الفتيات يعملون اليه عند
الاقبال على الشراء قبل معرفتها
كما يتميز لها بعيار 14 بتكلفته المتواضعه
مقارنه بالاعيره الاخرى كذلك يعتبر الاعلى
مكانه والاكثر قدره على تحمل معيار 18 في
الذهب في مستوى رايه العالي فيه يجعل
يجعله اقل احتماليه لتسبب في حساسيه الجلد
لاصحاب البشره التي تاثر سريعه
براز عيوب الذهب عيار 18 كونه انعم اسهل
للخدش في الاضافه الى سعره المرتفع